Next up we'll talk about creating a blueprint for pre-computed lighting and what we'll
cover here is we'll talk about some level streaming and we'll give you an overview
of the walkthrough and how you may go about setting up different lighting scenarios.
So in an empty map here I've just called my map level streaming and for this purpose
it's important to know about naming conventions and what we're streaming here.
It's completely up to you what you call them but you just need to make sure they're consistent.
So the first thing I'll do just to show you an example of this even though this isn't
necessarily lighting I'm going to show you a post-process example here.
So what I'll do is I'll just make sure this isn't ticked by default, yours shouldn't
be ticked by default and then I will first type unbound into my post-process and I will
tick that and it essentially just means the post-process affects the entire world and
then I will go to scene color tint which is under the miscellaneous tab inside of color
grading I'm just going to give this a color say of pink and then just so you know what
properties have changed what's a useful button to click is the settings option here and if
you show only modified properties I like this functionality when you're trying to dial in
certain properties that you've already adjusted it kind of cleans up the menu a little bit
so up to you if you want to use that.
What I will do is I will go to the levels tab and if you don't have this levels tab open
by default you can just go to a window and then you just want to make sure levels is
selected there and you can drop it in whichever window you would like and then I will go to
levels and create new I'm going to create an empty level and I'll create it and my
first map was called level streaming which you'll see at the top there so I'm still
going to call this level streaming and then I'll call this underscore pink for example
which is the pink level.
Now I've got this level currently selected you can see this highlighted blue now if you
think about this in terms of like almost like a layer in Photoshop or any other program
that you use this is the currently selected layer if I double click the persistent level
again which is our level streaming we've got a persistent level here so now I've got almost
like a sub layer of this persistent level so with it double clicked I'm going to select
my post process volume I'm going to hit ctrl and m and that actually moves the volume onto
the pink level streaming if I change the visibility of this level now if I hide it that's removed
that post process volume so if I toggle it on and I toggle it off that will hide and unhide it.
Now if I go to file save all even if this level is visible when I click play so I'm just going
to hit alt and p I'm playing this level now but you can't see the pink now that's because
this level is not loaded by default if you wanted it loaded by default you could right click change
the streaming method and go to always loaded and therefore it removes the little dot next to it
and when I hit alt and p to play it's now loaded so I don't want this loaded by default so I'm just
going to right click change streaming method and go back to the blueprint version of streaming method
because that's what this tutorial is about and you'll see the little dot there and whenever
you're working with lighting as of course this is a post process volume at the moment but if you're
working with lighting it's good to take the toggle lighting scenario and that makes Unreal account
for some pre-computed lighting scenarios and so if you had like a daytime scene a nighttime scene
a golden hour scene for example you could toggle the different lighting scenarios and it would be
pre-baked into that and all light maps would be stored inside of this stream level instead of
baking it on the asset so if you're wanting to just toggle lighting scenarios that's a really
powerful tool to have. I'm just going to file save all and now what I want to do is I want to
create maybe two or three more versions of this pink level so I can show you how we're toggling
through these different scenarios so I'll again go to levels I'll create a new level I'm going to
select empty level again I'll pre-select something that was a pink one and I'm just going to rename
it to green for example and I'll do that and then I'll do a last one create new empty level
I'll again get the naming convention and what colors should we go for there let's go for orange
so I'll save that and I go to file save all and then we want to go back and find our post-process
volume so if I go to the outliner and I find the post-process volume sometimes it's good just to
create a naming convention as well so maybe I'll call this pp underscore pink so I know which
post-process volume it is now the pink post-process volume is on the pink level as we saw before
now if I have say a different level selected so now the orange level is selected and I duplicate
this post-process volume and if I hide now the pink level you'll still see that post-process volume
quite faintly here on the left hand side if I turn off the visibility on that pink level that
post-process volume disappeared and because I duplicated this post-process volume with the
orange level selected this post-process volume is now on this level so instead of hitting control
and m like we did before I've just duplicated it onto the current streaming level so I'll go to
my scene tint I'll go to orange select new and then what I'll do is I'll duplicate this again by
holding down alt on my keyboard and I'll do the different method this way so I'll double click
now on my green level and I'll hit control and m to move it onto the green level I'll change this
to green and if I hide my orange level now I've got my green post-process volume so let's just
save all and let's just check these are working so I've got my green I'll hide my green I've got
my orange and I've got my pink so this is just a really nice way of just pre-visualizing these
level streaming methods that we're going to be using now they're all going to be blueprint driven
so again just right click you don't need to change this it should be there by default but change
streaming method just make sure they're all on blueprint we don't want them loaded by default
so if I went to file save all and I just hit alt and p to play again no no colors are currently
selected so now let's jump into blueprints and actually get some streaming setup we will go to
blueprints at the top here and we will open our level blueprint and we will just pin this to the
top bar now it's important to note that each one of these levels also has its own level blueprint
if you wanted to house any code on there we're going to put all the code on the persistent level
this persistent level is loaded and visible by default so you generally want to put any key
information onto this persistent level streaming level but you can house blueprint code on level
streaming if you want I've also just quickly noticed that the toggle lighting scenario so if
these were all three lighting scenarios that you had lighting on that you wanted to bake you just
want to make sure those three are toggled there but let's jump into blueprints now we can just
delete what's currently there we don't need that and I'm just going to right click and press the
hash key on my keyboard you can press whatever input type you like but I'm just going to use
the hash key and again like previous examples you can change the input key if you want by selecting
this button here it goes orange and if I press c on my keyboard for example that input would
change to c so I always just start with hash just because it's the quickest input to find and then
you can change it from there pretty pretty easily so I'll just save and compile just make sure
everything's still working now the two functions that we want to be working with today is unload
which is unload stream level by name so this unload stream level by name and then we also want to
have a load stream level by name so if you type load you'll have load stream level by name as well
so these are the two levels that we want to be working with here so this will unload a stream
level this will load a stream level and the level name that it will load and unload is if we go back
into our tab it's these levels that aren't currently loaded so let's start with the green example
so the way I like to do this I like to right click on the stream level I like to find it in
the content browser when it finds it in the content browser I'll single click just to go into rename
mode or you can right click rename or you can even hit f2 on it but I'll hit ctrl c to get the
name and I'll go back into the level streaming and in load I'll go to a paste there so ctrl and v
just to paste that name in I copy and paste the names rather than manually typing them out
because these level names need to be exactly what the other level name is called so if you
misspell anything it could break your game so I'm just going to go to
unpressed hash key I'm just going to load this level just see let's see what it's doing
you can play around with the make visible after load I like to tick that and just compile and
save and if we go to level streaming now hit alt and p we're playing the game now I'm going
to hit the hash key and now I've loaded the green level in and you'll see that on this side here
the level is now visible so we've got the persistent level still loaded and now we're
streaming in this sub data so you can imagine now quite quickly that if you had a nighttime scene
a daytime scene and a golden hour scene you could then cycle through these different levels to test
out the different lighting scenarios that you might have in your experience here so we'll use
a multi-gate to toggle through each of these level streaming functions now so I'll just give
myself a bit of space and going back to a multi-gate that we've used previously I'll select
multi-gate here so I've got a multi-gate and I will load first the green and then I'll copy
by ctrl c ctrl v and I'll ctrl c ctrl v again I'll add a pin I'll go to the different out
outputs so again we're just reusing functionality that we've used previously now I will promote the
loop output to a variable as well we'll call this scene switch and again we can just rename this
variable up here if you want to rename it I'll give it a category I like to always keep things
organized here especially as your level blueprints start getting bigger so we'll just call this
streaming and you can also I just control uh compile and save sorry and then you can also
promote this to a variable we'll call this starting scene index or you can call this whatever makes
most sense to you in your level here and then we'll give it the category as well streaming so again
we're just repeating a lot of functionality we previously learned here and so we've we're streaming
the green level in first and then we'll go back into our level streaming we'll find our orange
level next I'm going to ctrl c and I'll ctrl v the next name into there and of course because
we've kept the same naming convention I could just type pink in here but just for uniformity
I'll just copy the pink name and I'll paste this name now an important key to note to
make here is we're loading in the levels but we're not unloading the previous level so let's go
ahead and use this unload stream level by name function now so I just want to drag that in there
I'm going to ctrl c and ctrl v and the reason why I need two is because I just want to make sure if
the green is loaded orange and pink are not loaded so I'm just going to grab orange paste here and
again copying and pasting will save you a lot of time and misspellings and then I'll just ctrl c
ctrl v and now it's just trying to work as efficiently with the keyboard as we can by
ctrl c ctrl v so if orange is loaded we want to unload the green and the pink if pink is loaded
we want to unload orange and green so green visible orange and pink not orange visible
green and pink not and then pink visible orange and green not and so as long as you have the loop
selected by default again you don't have to but what it will do is it'll make that infinitely
repeat itself so I just want to compile and save I go back into my level streaming I'll hit
alt and p now there's nothing loaded by default and you could set something on begin play if you
wanted but I'm just going to press the hash key I'm going to press the hash key again I'm going
to press the hash key again and we'll just keep cycling and so that's a really nice functionality
to test different lighting scenarios out within your maps the last thing I'll do just as a bit
of bonus cleanup I'm just going to select everything I'll hit ctrl I'll just hit c on the keyboard
sorry and we'll just call this level streaming setup or something like that it gives it a title
I can move this title around I'll maybe give it a bit of a comment color I'll maybe drop the alpha
just to make things look a little bit nicer maybe I'll change the font size as well because
this is quite a big powerful functionality in the level it just keeps things nice and organized
so hopefully that gives you a good idea about how you might use level streaming and
a pre-computed lighting within your levels